what patterns do you find in great
movies
well arguably you could say that every
movie is the same story being told over
and over again that there's really only
one type of story
but
in terms of like actual patterns
I just saw a film that really stuck with
me
which is I think I think it's called
luckiest girl ever or something like
that it's on Netflix Oh with Mila Kunis
yeah yeah yes I wanted to see that I
wanted really dark like trigger warning
I can't code it in enough of those okay
I didn't realize that going in and I
wish there had been a little bit more of
a like are you sure you want to watch
this because watching it was like oh my
god
um right and it's a great commercial
sorry to interrupt oh yeah that it
suckered me and I'm like I have to see
this tell me more yeah it definitely
yeah it was it was brilliant it was the
best film that I've seen in a really
long time
in terms of films that have stuck with
me
I think it's bravery and just like
getting in there and really talking
about
for me it's like the stuff where it's
like wow you really you really went
there and you were really showing this
like gross icky side of life that people
are really afraid to talk about
um and you you did it in such a brave
way it doesn't have to be gross I think
just bravery with handling your subject
matter
um again that's specificity you know
really being like I am not going to be
afraid to tell the story even with the
most innocuous story I think that people
tend to you can tell when a room filled
of Executives like made decisions about
a movie as opposed to a creative no
offense to all Executives out there no
offense to you but um
you can tell when a committee made a
movie rather than like a human
um because the committee is like well
based on off our data this is the
Teletubbies right the Teletubbies was
literally written by a computer
algorithm where the computer was like
here are all the things babies like and
that's what we got right it makes no
sense
um the day that I learned that was the
day that my mind was blown I'm like okay
now that hellscape of a show makes a lot
more sense to me as to like why that's
the product of a committee presenting
research that's what the Teletubbies is
as opposed to something like luckiest
girl alive that is just really
specifically about sexual assault is
about a school shooter is about these
things that we see and hear about in the
news and in our personal lives every
single day
um and not shying away from that
was there a moral to that story
yeah the moral to that one was
um don't try to hide from your trauma
like your trauma is inherently a part of
who you are and when you own your story
and you own your truth that's when
you're able to more authentically live
your life
do you think there has to be a moral to
every great story no I don't
I think that sometimes you can tell a
really great story and let the audience
decide
and that can be really powerful
and that's the beauty of a lot of Art
House Cinema is that you're like huh
weird how do I feel about that go home
and think about it you know that to me
that's just critical thinking a really
important skill for sure
you've talked about knowing who you are
and what do you want to say to the world
when did you figure that out when did
you figure out this is kind of my
mission statement or maybe that's not
I'm I'm projecting that onto you but I
think that's a beautiful thing to to
really like have that as your who am I
what do I want to say to the world and
then if I know who I am no one can take
that away from me
[Music]
um
oh I'm not sure there was a specific
moment I think it's just been a thing
that slowly
unfolded I think by the time
I was a young adult in my early 20s
I knew that
I wasn't happy with who I was
and for me that turned into an internal
journey of like who who am I literally
who am I what do I care about
um how do I identify right like what
what identities make sense for me how do
I see myself
slowly going on that Journey
and then
I didn't really get specific about
what it is I wanted to do until the
first time I actually produced something
I think sitting in that chair of like oh
I actually have to think about this I
don't just blindly show up and perform a
thing which is something I'd been doing
since I was a little kid you know really
being like the director of sorts of a
ship and how that ship is moving and
being like how do I want this to go from
start to finish how do I want people to
receive this 10 years from now
um that is when I started thinking about
oh maybe this is what I want to do it's
more than being like I want to be an
actor in Hollywood it's like Oh I wanna
I wanna tell a very specific subset of
story
and I am drawn to these types of story
of these these types of characters and
here's how I would do this and starting
to think critically about those things
like if I saw a movie that was not good
or TV show that was just no I would be
like how would I do it differently you
know if I'm going to critique another
artist's work I have to have an opinion
of how I would do it
so then starting to think about
yourself in that context I think is when
you start to get to oh what but what do
I want to do you know
so knowing who you are and standing up
in front of an audience let's say the
symphony and singing with all eyes on
you
versus knowing who you are and being a
producer or or possibly somebody a
director yeah maybe are they the same
thing or they're different
different hats almost to like put myself
back on that stage and be like because
that's almost like a scary thing all
eyes on you
not really no it's the same same thing I
mean of course as a producer it's over
like a longer period of time right it's
like I this is I've been working on this
script for years oh my God it's done
there she goes goodbye
um and then talking about it for forever
after because it's a thing that she
worked on and spent years on so you're
not going to stop talking about it
um it's just that the time frame is
different as opposed to the symphony
concert you're referring to where I was
practicing every day for that for four
or five months and then I got up there
and it was like time to do it
yeah and and it's it's interesting
because it's it's like you got to go
into a different Zone to do a show like
that you know just side note but it's
like you don't have time to be acutely
aware of your surroundings and be afraid
it's time to just be like
here we are
here are all these people expecting this
to not be terrible so I better deliver
um yeah I mean for me it ends up kind of
being the same thing I think I really do
believe that the more you are your
authentic self and the more you're like
living in alignment with your values the
less you have to fear because I can just
be like here's who I am and whether I'm
talking to like a wildly famous person
or a person that I met at CVS it's the
same you know if I'm singing on a stage
to 5 000 people or if I am
sitting in a room very intimately having
a conversation with a lovely human
um it's the same same thing
yeah
just being present which I think most
people don't give themselves the
permission to do or be
I think it's harder to today
because there's so many ways for people
to try to access you or there's so many
things to be thinking about
and um there are and I'm not afraid of I
guess accessibility I know that's
definitely at the celebrity tier of the
industry there's a lot of reasons that
people go into in more unaccessible
space I um I hope I can always be
accessible I had I had the pleasure of
meeting Keegan Michael Key at the Webby
Awards this year he was just he and his
wife were just really chill and lovely
like a lot of stars kind of like came in
for their award and left and he's just
like sat with everyone and if people
came up he talked to them and I was like
this is a balance that I want you know
in terms of you just saying
accessibility it just made me think of
this like I always want to be reachable
I always want to be accessible you never
know who might be someone that is a
dream collaborator of yours who hasn't
been born yet or who hasn't woken up to
who they are yet you know I think um
I just have to say that living
super authentically is just the way to
be it's just so much easier and it feels
so much better to like be in your body
and have a conversation or be in your
body and sing on a big stage right or be
in your body and be shooting on set
that's really high pressure it's just
it's gonna be more fun every time dare I
say things could be fun
was it always this way for you no
no I used to have a really big problem
with this Association I would just be
like not in my body I'm somewhere else
um
something I haven't really talked about
in an interview but I I struggle with
depersonalization and derealization
which means that sometimes if I'm not
careful like the world is not the way
you see the world for me
um it's just I will like see stuff that
isn't there
um
and that's just a symptom of like really
chronic bad disassociation from like
poor mental health in my life
so it's just an active choice to be
present
now is as scary as that sounds does that
actually help with performance
on stage yeah oh yeah it does I think um
so much of Performing whether it be
acting singing stand up I mean it's the
wide variety dancing and tap dancing you
know the wide variety of performance
arts that there are
um
at the end of the day your body is your
instrument so if you're cut off from
your body
you can't really use it
um if I'm like right now I I can feel
the chair that I'm sitting on I can I
can experience the air in the room like
I am present I can tell that I am hungry
like I'm I am fully present in in who I
am and where I am and so I can more
easily have a conversation with you and
know that everything I'm saying is
coming from a real place sorry
microphone
um
that's critical for performing if I'm
going to inhabit another person I have
to be able to inhabit myself right how
can I play Mary Sue effectively if I
can't live as Sheila effectively
I was watching uh My Week with Marilyn
it's it's great it's also very sad
there was a line in there maybe
um maybe I'm just projecting it but that
the people that are great at playing
other people it's because they don't
want to play themselves maybe they
didn't say that maybe I'm thinking that
I I've definitely heard that before you
know I think I think it can go both ways
I think there are some people who
their greatest joy and Escape is that
they get to inhabit someone else and
that that's healing for them I would
argue that it's healing and they like it
because it's the one time they get to be
themselves in a place that's safe that's
what I'm going to argue I think that
acting at the very least singing all of
these things storytelling performative
storytelling is really interesting
because it's about finding all the ways
that we are the same you know if I as an
actor and looking at a script and very
often people get excited about me
playing villains which I
but it's like I'll I'll read this like
completely Wackadoo backstory where it's
like wow what has this person gone
through and on the surface it's like
well they were held in the mutants
prison so and it's like you know weird
otherworldly stuff that is just not a
part of our world that is super fun if I
look at it from the surface like yeah
there's nothing relatable but it's like
strip back the layers and it's the same
like
generally there's something about that
character that is similar to me that's
why someone's interested in seeing my
take on it and if I can get over the
fear of being seen in that way and find
ways to make it safe and play and maybe
be like cool maybe there's a way I can
make this villain more empathetic and
relatable then I think that's when
really brilliant art comes through